the way he lets her be a dialog when
your mother first said I'd like you to
come and have dinner with me and Warren
Buffett will be here you should meet him
you didn't seem that interested why was
that well Warren I thought of somebody
who bought and sold securities which is
a very zero something that's not curing
disease or a cool piece of software and
the idea of you know kind of looking at
volume curves and it doesn't invent
anything and so I thought my way of
looking at the world what I wanted to
figure out do and what he looked at that
there wouldn't be much intersection and
that's why it was so shocking when I met
him he was the first person to really
ask me about software and software
pricing and why wasn't IBM with all of
their strengths able to overwhelm
Microsoft and what what was gonna happen
in terms of how software would change
the world and you know he let me ask him
about ok well why do you invest in
certain industries and why are some
banks more proper than others and he he
was clearly a broad systems thinker and
so it started a conversation that has
been fun and enriching and you know an
incredible friendship that was
completely unexpected and he taught you
how to play bridge or did you already
know I knew how to play bridge but I had
done it just our family had done it and
then because Warren it was a chance to
spend time with Lauren I renewed my
bridge skill at first very poorly but
both golf and bridge were things that we
did in our hour hours that we got to
goof off together you've given up on
golf well Warren gave up on golf a few
years ago and so my primary excuse to
play golf has gone away so I'm I'm
golfing not much now tennis is become my
my primary sport Warren Buffett called
you one day and said by the way I'm
gonna give you most of my money were you
surprised when he said he wanted to give
you all this money from his wealth to
your foundation that was a a complete
surprise because Warren is the best
investor and he's built this humbly
company and he was giving me advice
about all the things I was doing I was
learning so much from him but his wealth
was devoted to a foundation that his
wife was in charge of and so tragically
she passed away and so then he had to
think that is his initial plan wouldn't
make sense and and much to my surprise
he decided that a part of the wealth a
little over 80% of it would come to our
foundation so it was a huge honor a huge
responsibility you know in an incredible
thing because it let us raise our level
of ambition even beyond what we would
have done without that that you know in
my most definitions the most generous
gift of all time